quand on se marie toujours faire un
contrat de mariage pour anticiper son
divorce
qu'on aurait pu évoquer avec lui
notamment comment ne pas faire plus même
enduite
c'est toujours compliqué et dans Love
avec ta mère franchement
tu sors là-bas
et le truc c'est c'est pas faire le
contrat de mariage en fait si à quel
moment le dire tu vois ou pas parce que
c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
je ne veux pas te mêler à mes affaires
imagine que j'ai un problème de justice
et bien tu pourrais compromises
le bilan tu peux toi rouvrir une autre
société par exemple c'est une communauté
réduite qu'est-ce qui signifie que ce
qui est Adelin est à l'autre donc c'est
pas si vous achetez un bien c'est pas
possible clairement vous dites ne faites
pas confiance à votre femme ou Marie
future ou alors soyez opportuniste ça
devrait être à la fille de dire on va
faire un contrat comme ça je te prouve
que j'en ai toujours madame qui gagne
moins non mais dans le cas c'est ce que
tu as dit juste
pas ça c'est pas ta femme
[Rires]
non mais c'est la femme pour dire Jean
on va faire un contrat je te montre que
je ne te pousse pas pourtant l'inverse
quand c'est la femme qui a beaucoup plus
simple il se trouve que vous parlez de
statistique c'est plus souvent comme
l'homme qui a beaucoup d'argent trois
fois sur quatre c'est madame qui demande
le divorce
[Rires]
galocher deux filles tout à l'heure
tu vois les dégâts
c'est lui qui avait fait de la merde au
soir là ça me tombe dessus moi j'ai
entendu que c'était vous donc la
fidélité est-ce que c'est une faute et
bien pas systématiquement
c'est pas nécessairement une faute
existe toujours mais il faut un
manquement grave ou renouveler aux
obligations du mariage dans les dans les
contrats hollywoodiens ou les voilà bon
il y a des conduits qui sont très très
détaillés justement sur l'infidélité sur
par exemple si dans les moins de 5 ans
tu me trompes avec Gisèle tu paieras à
temps tant de nanas dans le dans ton lit
c'est tant et puis voilà mais là il y a
des jours intéressants ne pas avoir de
relation sexuelles ça peut être
sanctionné
ça ça n'aura pas de valeur ça n'aura pas
de valeur quand
vous livre Comment qui vient vérifier
alors on peut faire des constat
d'huissier ça se fait de moins en moins
généralement on se fait peur
à des détectives qui vous suivent alors
justement peut-on tromper
à Guillaume comme on fait
en plus
alors il y a l'adultère virtuel aussi
qui existe désormais ça veut dire
s'inscrire sur un site de rencontre peut
être considéré comme une faute et ça il
y a de la jurisprudence là-dessus et
donc cliquez ça peut être trompé donc
faites attention à vous aussi en plus en
avion alors là là tu dérouilles mais
après s'il y a divorce pour faute il y
aura un octroi de dommage intérêt moi le
message c'est ne vous laissez pas faire
et demander le maximum si vous allez au
divorce
comment obtenir le pactole en cas de
divorce c'est bien les questions sont
directes alors on peut obtenir une
pension alimentaire pour les enfants ça
c'est qu'on soit marié ou pas marié et
bien sûr si la pension alimentaire est
impayée parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'hommes qui ne payent pas les pensions
alimentaires et ce sont souvent les plus
fortunés ça on peut quand même ne pas
les féliciter là j'explique vraiment la
procédure que faire en cas d'un pays
sait faire mais je crois que vous avez
pas d'enfant
[Rires]
un avocat commun par exemple si alors
justement à l'amiable depuis 2017 on a
plus le droit d'avoir un avocat pour
deux ça c'est depuis le 1er janvier 2017
c'est chacun son avocat et c'est mieux
pour les conflits d'intérêt et il y a la
prestation compensatoire aussi
exactement ça c'est pour généralement
c'est vrai que c'est pour Madame il faut
qu'il y ait une disparité causée par
leur rupture du divorce généralement
c'est madame qui a arrêté de travailler
pour les enfants local plus classique
est-ce que c'est vrai que la prestation
compensatoire peut s'appliquer si par
exemple le divorce est dû à une faute
entre guillemets une infidélité de
Madame
bien sûr demander une prestation
compensatoire c'est décorer les ça
dépend notamment de la durée du mariage
le message aussi pas de mariage pas de
prestation compensatoire d'où l'intérêt
de se marier c'est quand même plus
protecteur surtout quand la femme trompe
son mari
c'est autre chose non non
l'infidélité admettons nous sommes en
couple ensemble moi je vous trompe je
peux vous payer des dommages intérêts et
vous pouvez me payer une prestation
compensatoire
de se marier justement pour ne pas
assumer leurs obligations plus tard sauf
que c'est pas particulièrement très
courageux mais justement par exemple
dans ces cas-là si on a une vie si on a
une vie commune très longue avec la
personne et qu'on sait pas marié on peut
on peut arguer quand même du fait qu'on
a par exemple 10 ans de vie commune
justement là j'avais une personne qui
est venu me voir après 26 ans de
concubinage la prestation compensation
donc vraiment c'est il y a beaucoup
d'hommes qui se disent je ne vais pas
marier pour ne pas payer de prestations
pendant 20 ans elle habite avec la
personne qu'elle a participé au ménage
au bout de 20 ans le mec se barre s'il a
une maison il garde la maison lui tout
seul elle peut pas dire je veux la
moitié de la maison elle aura juste une
pension alimentaire pour les enfants
dans tous les cas Pax mariage
concubinage mais là vraiment euh faites
quelque chose pour les impayés ça reste
la procédure dans mon livre et comment
obtenir le maximum c'est pour les femmes
qui se retrouvent après 20 ans sans
avoir travaillé et sans rien changer il
faut prendre l'habitude de tout négocier
aussi ah oui là je suis une championne
pour ça je me crois dans le sentier je
négocie tout ça veut dire que par
exemple chez le coiffeur ça vous voit
pas vous râler en Gilles la coiffure
parfois
elle est incroyable c'est pas top je te
vois sur l'écran sur les extraits je te
vois parfois je dis tu vois c'est les
deux douches par semaine je sais pas
trop mais
parfois tu dis beaucoup de conneries
et donc je te donne des conseils pour
négocier si ton coiffeur a manqué pour
négocier par exemple il te fait quelque
chose de complètement raté tu dis ça ne
me va pas tu négocies gestes commercial
la plupart des gens ils sont chez le
coiffeur merci beaucoup ça me plaît
ça vous plait derrière comme ça donc
faut négocier après le coiffeur est tenu
à une obligation de moyens et pas de
résultats il est tenu aussi d'afficher
les prix donc dès que vous voyez un
enfant faut s'engouffrer dans la brèche
et négocier pour le restaurant eux ils
s'engouffre vachement Raymond
faut négocier si c'est pas bon alors si
vous avez tout le bruit compliqué mais
si vous n'aimez pas vous dites pas enfin
vous demandez votre réponse
parce que je fais un premier restaurant
c'est pas bon je suis en Première
restaurant
je mange un petit peu c'est pas bon je
m'en vais je fais l'autre en face c'est
pas bon je m'en vais et je mange un
petit peu à chaque fois ça c'est une
bonne technique de rap
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
téléphonique au bout d'un an de contrat
il faut appeler dire la concurrence m'a
proposé moins cher généralement ça
marche
[Rires]
session comment déshériter ses enfants
ingrats
on ne peut pas après on peut aussi faire
un viager et si il n'y a plus rien à la
fin c'est facile de déshériter il y a
des gens qui contractent beaucoup de
dettes si le passif est supérieur à
l'actif au bout d'un moment il y a plus
rien
à l'étranger résidence fiscale ça
d'autre l'ont fait je passe personne
autour de cette table à ma connaissance
donc on peut non personne
comment on fait parce que je suis pas là
pour avoir un jugement moral il y a des
gens à l'étranger parce que dans
d'autres pays on peut dans d'autres pays
on a beaucoup plus de latitude notamment
dans les pays anglo-saxons dans les pays
de commonwe donc les pays comme la
France on ne peut pas sauf certaines
exceptions qui sont dans le livre et
j'explique
en France c'est la moitié qui va à
l'enfant c'est ça
il y a une partie qui va venir de droite
j'ai fait trois fois le code je me suis
fait trois fois le code j'ai bloqué
son téléphone
alors oui on peut à condition de ne pas
être vu sinon ça peut être de
l'exhibitionniste
voyeurisme parce qu'il y en a qui
prennent des jumelles et qui regardent
ça aussi c'est un délit qui est
sanctionné
ça t'intéresse
je pensais que chez soi justement il y
avait pas d'exhibitionniste tu as
complètement raison à condition que ça
ne se voit pas tout le temps j'ai jamais
eu de problème
c'était sur le balcon comme ça
t'intéresse beaucoup cette thématique
Gilles qu'est-ce qu'on risque sinon
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai une question j'ai divorcé de ma
première femme ah oui j'ai une rentrée
d'argent par exemple et je veux la
donner mais jumeaux que j'ai avec Lola
et mon ex-femme réclame me dit que je
désire de son enfant c'est la première
fois
donc comme si je reçois par exemple je
gagne le loto
me réclamer il peut réclamer la part de
de l'enfant ne confondez pas c'est pas
pour elle c'est pour votre enfant mais
elle peut réclamer pour l'enfant pour
nos premiers enfants pourront avoir une
répercussion sur la succession à venir
ah effectivement après la question c'est
est-ce que c'est un cadeau ou une bonne
action
ça vous appauvrir un cadeau si ça dépend
de vos revenus après je ne connais pas
vos revenus mais si vous m'envoyez moi
un cadeau oui tu peux faire un cadeau de
5 millions d'euros
de la situation personnelle de l'offrant
et à partir d'un certain temps c'est bon
là c'est bon c'est très bon quand même
la procédure pour se faire rembourser le
train et l'avion c'est laquelle
ah j'en ai parlé j'ai que je veux pas
vous expliquer toute la procédure qui
est dans le livre mais j'en parle
beaucoup parce que tous les avions que
je prends sont en retard et les gens en
fait moi je râlais mais je ne faisais
rien maintenant je remplis le formulaire
je l'envoie je me fais rembourser une
partie de combien de justement ça dépend
de la distance et là j'ai expliqué avec
tous les tirets si c'est hors de l'Union
Européenne ou dans l'Union européenne et
toute la distance parce que ça dépend
beaucoup et la procédure est tellement
compliquée et c'est toute la
problématique de ce livre c'est que
c'est le Parlement européen qui a mis
cette ce texte qui est incompréhensible
et en fait c'est ça l'objet de ce qu'on
a tous des droits mais on ne les
comprend pas et si on ne les comprend
pas on les met pas en pratique